[Musica]
è la fit ragazzi è benvenuta questo
nuovo video sono fa vj ed oggi siamo su
cosa dite che siete rimasti estasiati da
questo accento english creati col time è
un videogame di horror che private
consiste da quanto ho capito
nell'uccidere la gente poiché per
credono so vivevo in un piccolo cottage
isolato dalla città di selezione ed il
silenzio regnava in quel posto
la mia casa è la specie l'inespugnabile
prigione è il cir ping degli dei
dell'isa nera [ __ ] che ne so ma
parole impossibili ilike mi piace sono
del vento la miglior traduzione degli
ultimi secoli ragazzi sono partito senza
senza sapere nulla cioè non so neanche
che cazzo è successo comunque vediamo di
far conoscenza con gli ospiti perché
ancora non ho visto nessuno ciapela
gioca come se ti dispiace se ricordo il
culo non è che non c'è niente di in
contrario ero ok cipro non ti noti
cazzaro detto a me è come un giorno lei
bellissimo taglio di capelli a vico via
e gli ospiti dovrebbero arrivare presto
non dovrebbero
non lo so io no io sono io sono qui per
caso non lo sapete che come mai qui la
fa vj tv e sventa perché non è normale
comunque va bene
buongiorno a tutti un tir
finora il tuo discorso è quello che ho
capito di più dunque c'è che chi è
questo sembra police a parte se non
volevo venire qui mi manca la mamma è
allora che cazzo ci fai qui se ti sei
perso 6 entrati sta casa minchia sentite
ma com'è che avete the screen l'ex di
preciso che qua si balla non lo so cos'è
sta roba per sprezzato internet ci sono
degli ospiti in casa mia non posso
lasciarla a questa è casa mia e titolo
suo mito e che ne so io corna perfetti
sono ospiti quindi non posso servire le
scale posso andare accesso se mi scappa
da cagare o no
chi è questa giorno per caso a sono
felice aiutati con la scena ma è grazie
pil
se no io ed è da solo non ce l'avrei
fatta grazie veramente potesse passarmi
quel coltello che c'è sul tavolo per
favore taglierò il pane così possiamo
servirlo perché i ragazzi allora vediamo
di passarli il coltello che c'è sul
tavolo
eccola crescenzi cioè come che faccia
passati coltello non trova il tasto
tasto è f capito ho capito modo anna ok
ho sbagliato
hai visto hai visto è hai visto che sono
è stata lei no non l'ho ucciso io volevo
passargli il coltello ma se non già le
mani di merda non è colpa mia
oh mio dio l'hai uccisa l'ha incisa
aiuta ucciso ma [ __ ]
ma presto andro titanio self da devo
premere contro per calmarmi ma non è
morta dai che ti rialzi vieni sommava
che gli è caduto pomodoro cazzo mi ha
chiesto scherzando
vieni qui ragazzi sono sono scappati
imperfetto limitati sono andati a
[ __ ] non c'è più nessuno
io non ho fatto niente allora io vi
spiego la faccenda io avevo il coltello
poi le mie mi passi il coltello un po
forte io ho detto tieni pieni e non l'ha
preso va beh non è colpa mia sono
spariti tutti ragazzi del cazzo suono
devo andare devo andare il sotterraneo
per accendere la corrente perfetto per
tagliare la corrente scusate perfetto
devo spegnere le luci di casa va a
fantastico ed evo devo scendere perfetto
da ci siamo mai così ragazzi minchia che
cantina ma cos'è lang harper the jet
fatemi capire
buongiorno senta lei mica visto dove il
caso da tagliata questo perché grazie io
ogni taglio è taglio qui questa eccolo
lì grande e tu chi cazzo sei come ti
permetti di entrare in casa mia
senti porta questo cortelli cucina fammi
un favore
ok che cazzo successo ragazzi era una
tizia senti chi chi chi cazzo sei tu
devi a 6 mar
anna è morta sta tizia e racca credo
fosse mia moglie che fosse però quello
era mica lo spirito di mia moglie spero
di no comunque siamo abbiamo tagliato la
corrente quindi adesso posso andare a
cercare la gente farla fuori come si
deve ma non importa allora facciamo così
usiamo st scusa io faccio finta di
preparare la nutella a tutti
quasi tutti pensano che io sia un bravo
ragazzo dove siamo un sito ma chi cazzo
sei bill gates per vivere in una casa
così fammi capire lo devo fare qualcosa
in giardino che non ho capito cosa
buongiorno senti erano veramente
veramente sera ma non importa
amava sta tizia tu la conosci devi
toglierti dalla mia vista torna in
cucina donna perfetto è tornata in
cucina e siamo a posto
comunque voglio capire ciò che è giusto
succedendo buonasera senta helen
guardiamo le stelle insieme 9 che sono
bellissime ascolta no vieni qui vieni
qui se sei un [ __ ] defilato ma
[ __ ] come ti permetti vieni qui
ragazzi ho perso l'invitato valorizzare
ce lo porta qui ecco tecla non puoi
scappare ascolta vieni qui vieni qui
dove devi portare il coltello di più se
la vieni qui a ok perfetto no no non
voglio ucciderti questo allora ascoltami
non voglio farti del male però devo
farti del male
ok ti ho detto che devi andare in cucina
io voglio dare il mio cui dello alla
gente in modo molto gentile ma la gente
non lo prende e si infilza non è colpa
mia amici miei dove si è testo venendo
di sopra ragazzi sono have to say quella
roba lì che cazzo hai nappi è una
finestra meno male pensavo fosse uno
spettro qualcosa del genova bene
sentite ed evo devo trovare i miei
invitati non è che per caso li avete
visti lampada tu hai visto qualcosa di
melo di melotti ammazzo ragazzi sta
diventando scena la situazione non
importa quanti c'è sky maledizione non
so se da soli in casa cioè 20 cessino
questo il quadro più bello in hd che
abbia mai visto velocità
poi via bastardo no vai via tu bruta
stronza devi tornare viso alla cucina e
18 18 perfetto che voi tra ragazzi cos'è
sta roba
c'è la scultura di una papera perché che
spero sia una scultura e non una papera
viva perché se non ha senso è un'arma
dei bellissima donna che quadri
fantastici buongiorno senza è non è che
per caso mi fa vedere il suo bel culetto
non sa perché mi piace vieni qui vieni
qui brutta stanza veliche al tu che ci
fai nel mio di mano e mio divano
[ __ ] mi scappano tutti donna devi
devi toglierti dalle palle non hai
capito dove siete tanto vi trova inutile
e vieni qui cosa fate [ __ ] in casa
mia cosa cazzo una baffo almeno state
fermi se dovete farlo sono andati di
soldi ho visti io ho visto tanto vi
trovo e vi farò del male quando vi
troverò sappiate ecco che ecco timbrarlo
vuole piuttosto ronzo mori è inutile che
fai portato in casa me la devi smettere
di importunare i miei invitati sono i
miei invitati non dargli fastidio
ascolta ma la tizia che stavi parlando
prima dov'è andata no perché mi serve
devo devo devo darle il mio colte salve
a chi hai chiesto il permesso di fissare
del mio accesso amico mio allora
ascoltami lo so che sei talmente nano
che non arrivi alla tazza del cesso però
è solo tira l'autorizzazione di usarlo
fatti un bidet fatti o meno quello morto
nello anno ho detto a lui di farsi un
bidet e non a te donna deve spiegarmi in
attimo che cosa ci facevi dentro il mio
accesso perché non è una cosa normale
aiuto lo dico e poi fai quel che vuoi
manca manca la notizia o coi capelli
rossi manca manca la donna è poi teoria
dovrei aver finito solo che non potè
questo faceva parte del mio piano
diabolico
anche questo intervento è attento
intenta in tintin tanto in tanto per
tanto in tanto incantando terzetto in
testa certamente 7 tel
[ __ ] che cazzo mi ha visto male
ligia vieni qui vieni credo nostra vieni
qui pervertito cosa ci faceva il mio
giardino dillo che ti masturba vico
cespugli della dove vai dove chiara
e brutto stanza vieni qui dovesse andare
dove cazzo si è nascosto a brava ha
trovato la un'app la brava un mi piace
perché è riuscita a trovare la cucina ci
sta tutto secondo me il bastardo si è
ficcato di sotto non voglio che ci fai
qui tu brutta [ __ ] vieni vieni passardi
2 1 2 in 1 con fissato sia sia la tizia
che questa crisi sono capisci della
frase bagni a preparare un panino di
nutella non è difficile non è
fottutamente difficile se sei disco a
prenderlo da dietro magari non se ne
accorge foca e lo prendono scapparono
scappare non scappare uno strato sei
morto e inutile che scappi vieni qui
vieni qui se facciamo un bel panino
vieni qui a ok e non ti cassare di vivo
in un piccolo cottage isolato dalla
città che cazzo il successo
il silenzio è regna in questo posto sono
le frasi dell'inizio la mia casa e
quelle tipo una prigione il doc lei non
si può fuggire o per il cir p new delhi
sparrow che sarebbero tutti gli uccelli
vabbè comunque mi piace il suono del
vento perfetto la sigla una traduzione
più fantastica degli ultimi secoli
così calmo e finito così ragazzi ho
fatto un genocidio di gente da a3 è un è
un gioco italiano fantastico i
programmatori sono italiani bravissimi i
complimenti perché mi è piaciuto un
casino soprattutto la parte in cui
affettava la gente nella morale di
questo gioco e se dovete fare un panino
alla nutella coltello dovrebbe infilarlo
nel pane non nella gente comunque grazie
per avermelo consigliate soprattutto
state attenti di notte perché giro per
casa in cerca di nutella quindi via via
avvertito che i ragazzi sedi dove è
piaciuto come al solito lasciato un
commento mi piace anche la pagina di
facebook e come ogni video trovate nella
descrizione se la sera coristi
iscrivetevi ci vediamo al prossimo vinto
bene ragazzi